on s'est rencontré sur les réseaux
sociaux il est à venir vers moi il m'a
approché il m'a envoyé un message et
puis on a commencé à échanger voilà par
par message et puis très rapidement on
est venu à se rencontrer il m'a proposé
qu'on se rencontre au restaurant très
rapidement j'ai vu des signaux d'alerte
j'ai découvert il y avait beaucoup
d'argent en liquide des faux papiers des
chèques en blanc qui n'étaient pas à son
nom la volé ma carte et il ne pouvait
faire que des paiements sans contact
donc voilà c'était un montant qui s'est
arrivé à du 200 300 euros il a pas pu
aller très loin c'est de la manipulation
et c'est ce qu'on appelle le Love
bombing c'est ce qui explique les psychi
les psychiatres notamment un psychiatre
américain là dessus et qui explique
qu'en fait c'est le fait de donner
beaucoup tout de suite aller très
rapidement dans la relation s'investir
beaucoup et créer une forme de
dépendance en fait quand on rentre dans
cette spirale finalement c'est très dur
en fait d'avoir d'être clairvoyant en
fait sur ce qui se passe il est il a un
quart serré mais alors il a pas été
sous-écrou par rapport aux arnaques mais
par rapport à une autre affaire avec une
de ses